Hey friend, storage is one of the most
important feature in AWS and today I
will share you the types of storage and
the details about the S3 storage. Now
whether you are new or you already know
them after watching this complete video
you can explain easily to anyone in your
interview confidently and yes not just
definitions like this I will explain
step by step with the help of diagram.
So stay with me and let's start learning
what is AWS storage. What are the types
of AWS storage? Now after listening to
this, you will feel more confident as a
developer. You know there are different
types of files that your application
handles. For example, there are readable
files like word file or PDF file. Then
there are images files like PNG or JPG
and also data files like CSV or uh text
files. Right? So to handle and to store
different types of data files in the
best way AWS provides different types of
storage services.
Okay. So the one the first is the very
popular one and that is Amazon S3.
Simple storage service. S3 stands for
simple storage service. S3 is best used
to store unstructured data like images,
videos, backups, documents and more.
Okay. It is the most popular one because
nowadays everyone is creating videos,
watching videos, right? And the videos
you are watching right now maybe it is
also hosted in some AWS hosted website.
If it is in AWS then the this video is
stored in S3 storage only. Okay. Second
type of storage is Amazon EFS elastic
file system. EFS provides cloudbased
shared file storage. Okay. And the third
type is Amazon EBS which stands for
elastic block storage which provide
block level storage. Okay. Now I know I
know I'm just giving oneeline answer
right now but don't worry in the
upcoming question I will explain each of
these AWS storage in detail with the
real example like when to use which one.
Okay, that I will explain more because
that in interviews they will ask you
when to use this storage, when to use
that storage like this. Okay, but yes,
now you know the main types of a storage
and here is a simple and easy to
remember definition. AWS storage is a
cloud-based storage solution that allows
you to store, access, and manage data
over the internet safely and reliably.
I hope this diagram and definition in
this book will help you in doing the
quick revision before your interviews
from this book.
Explain Amazon S3 storage. When would
you use it in your project? Get ready.
After listening this, you can explain
this to anyone. Let me explain with the
help of an example. Suppose you have
some EC2 instances or be beantock
instances where your applications are
running. Okay. Now from these
application this EC2 and this beanto
your app is running here and from EC2
user are uploading the images from
beanto user are uploading the videos the
media files
and these
files media files send are coming to
your application and then the best place
to store these fly files is in AWS is
AWS S3 storage like this. Now the main
question is why is this is the best? Why
not other type of storage?
Because Amazon S3 is especially made for
storing the large unstructured files
like the media, images, videos,
documents and backups
and uploading and downloading media
files from S3 storage is very very fast.
Okay, for example, let's say you have
one another EC2 and one another beanto.
Okay. And from these two application
here applications are running. You want
to read the images from the S3. You want
to read the videos from S3.
Then you can directly access those media
files from S3 storage through a URL like
this. This is the URL. Okay. You can
just use this URL and you can download
those media files from the S3 storage.
And that is also very fast. That's why
we use S3 to store the large files like
images, videos. Okay. In short, S3 is
the best when you want to store large
files and access them via the URLs uh
URLs from web mobile cloud-based
application. Okay. Okay. And yes, there
is one limitation of that's same thing I
have written here also. First of all, S3
is stored for large backl
when you want to access easily URLs
especially in web mobile. There is a
limitation of S3 and that is here
editing files in S3 blob or you can say
blob storage manually is difficult
because the files are stored as objects
not as regular files. Remembers in S3
storage files are storage as objects. So
if you want to open the S3 uh storage
and you want to edit the file manually
that's very complex and that's not uh
what S3 is meant for. For that purpose
there is some other storage which is
Amazon EFS if you want to manipulate the
files and that I will explain you in the
upcoming question. But yes, this diagram
in the book and this definition will
help you revise your this Amazon S3
later in a better way from the book.
Right
before moving forward, a quick note
here. I created a complete AWS interview
preparation boot camp for you with three
powerful tools. Number three, 200 plus
AWS interview questions from all the
topics step by step even for AWS
beginners like this. Second, a PDF book
for quick lastm minute revision. And
first 10 AWS mock interviews to practice
like real interviews. Many student have
already cracked interviews with my
courses. All links are in the
description. If interested, great. If
not, no worries. Let's move to the next
question. What is Amazon EBS? How does
it support EC2 instances? Very simple. I
hope you already remember the basic idea
where EC2 instances are used to host
your application in the AWS cloud,
right? You already know this. Now, let's
talk about EBS. Okay, Elastic Block
Store. So, Amazon EBS provides
persistent storage to these EC2
instances like this.
So, now you you may ask what is
persistent storage mean? So, let's say
your EC2 instance is like a computer
running in the cloud. Now if your
application running in EC2
have some uh files storing some files
some database some important images.
Now to store the critical data you can
use EBS which is like a attached uh
storage in your main EC2 so that if
tomorrow your EC2 is crashed or stopped
because of any reason then the data
stored in in the EBS will be safe. Okay,
this is the job of EBS. So EBS you can
think of as SSD or hard drive to your
laptop or computer.
Here is the final definition. Amazon EBS
is used to provide persistent block
storage to EC2 instance so that your
data remains safe even if the EC2
instance is stopped or restarted.
Now you will ask what is the meaning of
block store in EBS? What is the block
store and what is the difference between
block store and the object storage? S3
is the object storage. This one is the
block storage and this I will explain in
upcoming question. Here is a short
question. What is the difference between
block storage and object storage? Let me
explain here is the differences I have
written. Okay. So see block storage is
mostly used with services like EBS and
EFS and in this data is splitted into
fixed size blocks. Okay. For example, if
in your computer you have different
folders, these are like different
blocks. Whereas in objects storage data
is stored as objects. Okay. So file with
metadata and S3 storage. S3 S3 don't
forget metadata. S3 storage is the
example for object storage. Okay. Next
difference is to access how to access
block and object storage. Okay. Access
method. So block storage you mount like
a hard disk via NFS. Okay. Like you
access your computer fileers via paths.
Whereas object storage is will be
accessible via you sorry HTTP API or
URLs URLs especially. So this is like a
hard with some path it is via the URLs.
Okay.
When to use what use case is what block
storage is used with databases. If you
want to store your database then use
block storage some operating system then
you can use low latency apps for that
object storage you can use in case of
media files images
okay big unstructured files. So that is
the difference between block storage and
object storage.
Great job my friend. Now one more
important type of storage is EFS. very
important for interviews that I have
explained in my complete AWS interview
boot camp.
Many of my students have already used my
courses to crack their interviews. Now,
if you don't want to miss a single
question for your next interview, then
check out the boot camp and book link in
the description below.